crushing birth rates is not going to
solve
the climate crisis
for a few reasons one is that it takes
too long right if the problem is that we
currently have close to 8 billion people
who are living in such a way that you
deplete natural resources as time goes
by which I think is true
um
having you know 1.5 replacement rate or
something like that below below the 2.1
necessary for replacement
is not going to
you know if Extinction rebellion and Co
a right that we're talking about
apocalypse within a century that's not
quick enough right to actually reduce
the burden on the planet so
that kind of gentle decline in
population is nowhere near enough to
avert catastrophe if that's the only
tool that you're employing